this week we've got TP pulse frozen
Caesars and cash bail
all Caesars Pizza juicers like Caesars
that's how much you've ruined the
English language for us bro we can't
tell the difference between Caesars and
Caesars it's not really an easy powers
forever story there's this thing that's
gone viral in China where people are
putting their fitness trackers that
detect heartbeats on toilet paper mugs
bananas like circular things we're
trying to game the system and show off
like hopping in with steps they took and
they're just hitting the toilet paper
all watching it spin no it's for
heartbeat so they're saying like what
the hell my toilet paper has a heart
rate it's faulty it does come out that
it does have a reading that's like
toilet paper has like a resting heart
rate of 81 beats per minute I need
toilet paper add feelings why are you
here it's cream every time you're wiping
your ass [ __ ] no it Sam what a shitty
job dude have you guys ever just
something so big a tour your ass hmm
yeah that [ __ ] happened to me two
days ago I sorry I got hemorrhoids very
good well that's actually cuz I got too
much [ __ ] fiber and that [ __ ] was way
too solid and that [ __ ] came out so way
too much fiber makes it salt doesn't it
yeah I think so yeah too much my
roommates are wrong yeah do you need
more water then I you you should just
shouldn't you have to regulate how much
fiber you have to which I didn't oh it's
a balance of fiber and fat yeah so Mike
my [ __ ] was [ __ ] rock-hard and that
[ __ ] tore my [ __ ] dude like ice cream
oh I had the opposite I had too much
protein not enough fiber and I had
constipation and hemorrhoids and once
that [ __ ] came out [ __ ] a new
person huh yeah but it was a slow roll
man never doing that again
yeah he's pretty bad dude I get Torah
and a little blood came out that was on
my period this was terrible
booty period I found out Lucky Charms
makes you poop green oh really
hey Lucky Charms a night before I woke
up took [ __ ] was it like that no right
I'm lucky charm clover green and jaws is
a very clear lucky charm I agree
it could beat the milk drink milk I did
drink milk by Google does lucky charm
make your poop bean and it does yes they
do that on purpose it's a special dye
they use in their in their marshmallows
I was freaking out awesome that's like
when you eat beets you don't think you
just [ __ ] blah my god that is so scary
forget like oh no wait it was just beets
I love roasted golden beet
I don't eat leaves brilliant me neither
it tastes like dirt sweet it does I just
drink it as it what you guys never had
roasted golden beets with [ __ ] a
honey-roasted dirt honey salt and
oregano
that sounds roiled it's [ __ ] good so
you just want to cover up the flavor of
the beef no beets beets are already
sweet as it is it is kind of nutty if
you roast them like nice yeah I love
them but it's super good man go I never
tried a golden beet maybe I'll try one
of those guys yo man it's not red it's
yellow it's golden it's golden it's like
gold yellow I never tried that but all I
know is if you try to put beets in a
shake that should taste like you got a
scoop of dirt scoop of sugar and you
made a shape yeah man I'm gonna make
ya'll some roasted golden beets they're
alright
basically let's do it yeah so this whole
fitness tracker toilet paper heartbeat
thing it's because the way that these
fitness trackers track your heartbeat is
green lights and it's to track the blood
flow because blood absorbs the green
light and so does toilet paper it turns
out and that's why it has its weird
heart rate that is your blood is related
to toilet paper or absorbs green the
same way it's the light yeah it's a
light reflection that's how it's able to
detect your heartbeat and it wasn't just
so they're mainly talking about this
Xiaomi fitness tracker it's a Chinese
Shou
Xiaomi me band 3 show me the money show
me the
being road lonely
that's perfect Chinese yeah but they're
saying it also happens to like all these
other fitness trackers like the Apple
watch and have you guys use those I
tried to I try to fit back it's pretty
cool so what does it do like just track
your mile or run oh the Fitbit one that
I was using it tracks the steps this um
distance and then also my heart rate cuz
it sometimes like you think you're
having a really good workout and I look
and I'm like and actually slack it off
right now my heart rates hell alone but
it just feels like me because I was
tired or had a long work day that I
thought I was putting out and I'm I'm
sweating but then my heart rate was like
pretty low so I actually was a training
at heart did the [ __ ] Apple watch if
you're not as active as you were before
like it kind of it's a little
condescending talk [ __ ] to you hey fat
ass basically that's what they're saying
oh really I'm gonna sleep in today it'll
come in it'll be like hey so you're not
as active as you were the day before
look [ __ ] Rosa cuz I'm like dogs don't
make me feel worse about my activity it
does it makes you feel bad about
yourself it does is that it's just like
you're not you have you're not doing as
well as you did the day before is it's
basically saying you're a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's why you don't see what if
you just did a marathon the other day
well that's what I'm saying so like five
miles yes
like within the week I also have this
app called pacer because you know I walk
every day so but pacer is really cool
because it is just geotags you so it's
not by you know how many paces it thinks
they're taking is based on it marks
where you're at and then you go it's
like a GPS thing the GPS thing so I can
better because uh the pedometers and
stuff like you could just like I could
just do this forever and I'll be like oh
yeah you walked that much or whatever
when you keep chasing a job hey today
I'm Tiffany Bonnie this is too funny
hello because that was her nickname that
she said what she say funny oh yeah
funny too no I remember things about my
friends do what's my last name huh god I
know it's Kwan now yeah god no I just
call you mrs. Kwan mrs. Kwan
our next story this video went viral and
it shows these frozen pizza
Oh Little Caesars Little Caesar Caesars
yeah my dollar pizza
bleep that went viral colleagues food
right there Little Caesars and ages this
can't be happening right in front of me
and the video is it not Little Caesar
I wonder why you picked this article
TIFF I pick it everyone maybe they ran
out of pizza that day yeah I read out
the joint
oh [ __ ] really would rather have you
Jordana huh that's so Chrissy Chrissy
Teigen
yeah the model the one that's married to
John Legend yeah sorry Johnny
Donnelly Kazama oh my god if the journal
bought Little Caesars and now they're
supplying to giorno I would go there
that's what she said she said the only
Little Caesars I want to go to yeah but
she got a sponsorship from DiGiorno
I like Little Caesars though I've tasted
better than to Jornal so I can taste the
day I could taste the difference if I
went to Little Caesars and then to
Jornal came up like this is buttom dish
or no this is not Little Caesars but
they're all they're all I don't think
one's better than the other I can taste
a difference it depends on my mood I
don't even remember what Little Caesars
tastes like anymore yeah it tastes like
cheap children's birthday pizza yeah but
to measure in the mood for that kind of
stuff this will has [ __ ] up that word
Caesars for me now all like picture is a
box with little scissors on it now babe
I love Little Caesars yeah Caesars but
man I like I think Little Caesars five
dollar pizza is better than the other
five dollar pieces though yeah
that's not talking about what other five
dollar pizzas are dummy no no me no
that's five dollar pizza no me no got it
they got the best five dollar pizza it's
good if we just get that if you don't
get fancy just get pepperoni I [ __ ]
love it you know what though just
talking about like cheap pizza I didn't
realize how many calories were in a
slice of pizza call well hon dude I in
heist like thirty thousand I know that
Fox and a half well Costco pizza is
really dense like the weight of it it's
not it's not light if you guys can look
it up on the internet right now look up
how much a slice of like pepperoni pizza
is that Costco it's ridiculous I feel
like they can fly through the whole
pizza - pizza they give you way more
cheese - then like a regular petrol
degree at Sam's Club and Costco is my
shirt I could fill up like a whole cup
full of
from the costume that's how it's done
right that's when it's delete I don't
like the bread at the Costco pizza it's
like bagel bread or so the crust is like
a little bent
yeah what I will say though that
pepperoni pizza that sheet that front
part I like the cheese in the pepperoni
what I don't like is the crust part the
dough cuz they share yeah that's why I
said yeah they share the dough with the
chicken baked dough so it's kind of like
it gets kind of hard it feels kind of
weird doesn't feel soft like pizza dough
yeah they fix that I love the cheese
they use I love it tomato sauce to use I
like the pepperoni they use my parents
used to buy this [ __ ] all the time cuz
I'm so cheap you know I mean I still
love fedko pizza you guys have Petco up
there
oh listen you've asked us like 20
million tell we don't have fedko but we
have a nut we have this cheap ass
[ __ ] supermarket that has their
version of pizza ten times better than
Costco people back same price was it
food Mac's food Mac no stop food Mets
it's [ __ ] um Winco Winco pizza oh
Winco pizzas I know when coke dude it's
so [ __ ] good man like made-up stories
oh when codes like pretty good Winco
they're real there's some real [ __ ]
when co pizza is the [ __ ] that they got
this [ __ ] Italian dude that looks
like Super Mario it sound like an Asian
guy who can't say wrinkled dude we go
Pisa I guess our near wing Kong [ __ ]
Dwight we know mr. my wink oh man I want
pizza now you guys ever have the dollar
so less frozen pizza as a single serving
the less the dollar ones in the grocery
store Oh as the lady on front you never
know I used to get those thirty cents of
burritos though F [ __ ] your food for
less let me tell you something else
instant diarrhea something something
real 30 cents because they were probably
expired bro no they are all 30 cents
it's terrible
[ __ ] diarrhea you know one that's
like green and brown oh they're so bad
they're not even a dog I don't trust
anything that that looks like 39 cents
yeah it's food and not a dollar
you can mix and match yeah I don't trust
it but you're in frozen burritos I love
that [ __ ] I love hot pockets - oh I love
how pocket so Little Caesars they
investigate it into the matter because
uh this Little Caesars is located inside
of a Kmart and they're saying that these
DiGiorno pizza robotics
close to closing time oh that's when the
manager tried the pool no I told the
employee to temporarily store them in a
cooler that was next to Little Caesars
and that's when someone caught that I
thought they were just they just bought
him they were gonna cook it in their own
imagine they were like we just got
hungry and we wanted pizza
I thought they ran out of pizza and
they're like quick what do we do and
then the franchise owners like the joint
oh yeah yeah if I ate that I'm like dude
Little Caesars really upgraded copy real
dough I love I love dinner it's really
visual I was really good [ __ ] good
especially the edge pieces on DiGiorno
pizzas the edge part yeah it's like
garlic bread mixed with a little bit of
pizza and food companies won't sponsor
me man like I'm like the spokesperson
for food I [ __ ] with it's so heavy no
they're not gonna do their [ __ ] dump
I was talking to the person that read
your note for you guys man they're the
is the brand's you're tripping they
wanna like they always like they always
move away from their demographic because
they know their actual demographic is
like the scum of the [ __ ] earth yeah
they don't want those people promote it
like promoting their brand so they want
like wholesome whatever I'm like you
know only divorce families eat your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's their demographic so I'm like you
should hire divorce families to promote
it but you have wholesome wholesome
channels that your guys's channel to
promote I'm like dude they're not even
promoting to the right demographic
yeah like Velveeta mac and cheese should
be like there's like [ __ ] parents
alcoholic arguing in the background and
the kids like hungry as [ __ ] and then
they [ __ ] make the Velveeta mac and
cheese and they feel good I would never
buy that no because they're already
buying it so like there have been people
that watch our videos in them and
there's they tweet at me they're like oh
my god thank you like you made me crave
some journa I've never had it before and
now I can fight see perfect I'll bring
trash food to the middle class soon yes
it is
it's comfort it's like bringing DiGiorno
to Beverly Hills yeah big name is they
need some good food that's they gotta
really go put it out like it's DiGiorno
auntie to floofy like they did a good
job sponsoring this girl banking because
she makes the journa look amazing and
she brings us to the parties and we get
to eat it I know an external party
that's coming up like tombstone pizza
[ __ ] I've never even tried that your
tombstone pizza bro [ __ ] good
California just signed a bill that will
replace cash bail with algorithms and I
know you guys are confused so you know
how I baling fools out of jail exactly
so you're gonna make them do math yeah
no right now the way it works is they'll
set a certain amount for your bail and
if you can afford it cool you're out
you're free into the world which is
craziness then you're [ __ ] you're just
gonna stay in jail until whatever which
is even crazier yes so now what they're
saying is that those accused of crimes
will be graded by an algorithm starting
October 2019 and so this algorithm will
determine if this person is at risk of
flight or committing another crime
during the trial process and so that
will mean that it will be more fair like
for people who can't afford to bail
themselves out now they'll be able to
assess that particular person never took
a killer case and see if like oh does
this person Oh like do they have to stay
in jail or can me I think that's way
better than the bail so ever friend
that's a cop and you told me recently
they raided like a cartel safe house or
whatever and they came up on like 12
kilos fentanyl which is extremely potent
[ __ ] that's what they cut like coke and
heroin with and then like you can inhale
it and die yeah oh sorry yes what the
rappers have a dying on yeah so the new
policy like before cops when they see
like those duct tape packages you poke
it with the knife so you can write in
the police port what it is now if you
poke it with a knife and the powder
comes out you can inhale and just die so
now you don't label what you think it is
or
do write what you think it is but you
don't verify you just send it to the lab
and don't do all the testing over there
but what he was saying is they rated on
these you know like every single [ __ ]
movie they do that and they taste yes oh
they are so they rated these cartel
fools to like dark ass Guatemalan
looking [ __ ] that don't speak
any lick of English but they drove like
a Mercedes like Gucci Rolex [ __ ] silk
ass shirt so it was just completely out
of their element right and they booked
them they brought him into jail the bail
was 2 million per person they were out
of jail in two hours yeah this cartel
[ __ ] is [ __ ] real like the amount of
resources they can pull in seconds it's
soy people like this they go to jail
right and then they're like this guy's
clearly caught cartel and then BOOM
money wire transfer comes in gets bailed
make it a billion that that pay yeah if
it was a billion it would take him a
week like sometimes when I watch these
shows like man you guys made so much
money you could just back down let
somebody else take the drug ring and
disappear off that money man I asked a
bar that's what I would have done it but
it's brought out oh is that what you can
get out huh I don't think you can man I
think there's what if I just groom
somebody I'd be like yo man I'm done
with this dude this is all you guys just
give me like a few billion and I'm good
[Laughter]
yeah a lot of people that are concerned
with this new law that's gonna be taking
into place next year is that AI they
tend to have since were like racial bias
cops putting it in exactly so that's
just the only thing that's concerning
but they are saying that they will be
having a review of how this AI system
works in 2023 so not until then we'll
see you I think a fair way to just do it
is does this person have priors do they
have a history of violence they have you
know you got to look at every specific
individual and then
and in in the crimes that they've
committed in the past or what they're
linked to versus like Oh black Asian
white you know like how do you feel
about those whole like you know how you
how you guys were just saying how you'll
just immediately get profiled because of
a certain way that you look at whatever
and then now there's this thing on your
record even though you didn't really do
it or just because you look like a
certain type then they'll immediately
book you for that certain thing but you
didn't really do I think it should be on
things that you were committed for if
you have a domestic violence or or you
know like there's all these other things
that you have a rap sheet then they base
it off of that because people can pay
bail and then like get away and then
commit the same crime again and in other
people who can't afford the bail they
have to stay in jail but it was like
nonviolent or like it wasn't that bad we
just gotta keep violent people off the
streets that's all but if they just like
I don't know like their cat burglar or
some [ __ ] and you know cats yeah yeah I
can't I just want to feel safe man yeah
yeah then I don't know you guys are so
reasonable I just pictured a man in a
[ __ ] black cat suit with it in a cat
suit yeah I saw the Pink Panther
[Laughter]
[Music]